Alemania anunció el lunes que dos de las
tres centrales nucleares que debían
cerrar a finales de año seguirán
operando hasta abril de 2023 en caso de
una posible emergencia energética el
ministro de economía insiste en que se
trata de una medida de crisis y que el
país tiene una seguridad de suministro
muy alta
es una decisión muy meditada porque se
trata de una tecnología de alto riesgo
que debe dejar de funcionar a finales de
este año pero creo que es justificable y
necesaria Y eso es lo que propondré al
gobierno o a los grupos de la coalición
explicó que los reactores contarán con
personal pero no producirán electricidad
a menos que se considere necesario y que
Alemania se mantendrá firme en su
intención de alejarse de la energía
nuclear el país europeo se ha opuesto
históricamente a este tipo de energía
desde el movimiento antinuclear de los
años 70 y tras el desastre de fukushima
en 2011 la excanciller Angela Merkel un
calendario para abandonar esta fuente
pero los conservadores de la oposición
acusan al gobierno de coalición de no
hacer lo suficiente para protegerse de
la crisis vuelvo a pedir al gobierno que
prolongue la vida útil de las últimas
tres centrales nucleares que siguen
conectadas a la red que ordene las
barras de combustible y que modifique la
ley de energía atómica ante la amenaza
de escasez de energía este invierno el
país ha intentado llenar sus
instalaciones de almacenamiento de gas
utilizando suministros de sus vecinos y
también se ha visto obligado a volver a
poner en marcha centrales eléctricas de
Carbón la fuente de energía más
perjudicial para el medio ambiente